[Music]
customers
are getting more diverse we think that
we know our customers best but actually
we don't we needed to understand the
profile of our customers
who they are now what exactly do they
need
users and customers are evolving and how
can we
touch these customers differently
satisfied customers can spend a whopping
140 more on a company's products
compared to those who had a poor
experience
so we can no longer deny that customer
experience
will become a key brand differentiator
in order to improve your customers
experience
you would first need to understand their
decision making processes
think about how a customer decides to
purchase something from your website
typically they don't make decisions on a
whim it's affected by the events that
led them to your platform
all the way till the purchase has been
made
this chain of events is called a
customer journey
this could be a journey of one type of
customer
aka what we call a persona or
it could feature a few different
personas
by clearly mapping out your customers
journey
you would be able to understand their
decision-making process
and experiences across the various
interaction touch points
which will in turn help you to identify
areas of improvements quickly
kentic is short for scandinavian design
tip furniture
we believe in a minimalist design we
sell
primarily indoor furniture my primary
business
is bringing wholesome soups to your
heart we believe that
to be eaten as a mew previously our
target market was very simple it was
just a one-liner 35 to 45 pm ebs
what are the products and what are the
services uh
that we want to create for our customers
what is truly
the soup spoon experience with this user
journey mapping we realized that we
could divide them further
into five different subcategories are
they bachelors
people with young families are they
quality conscious buyers
furniture refresh families there's so
many different categories
through the use of journey mapping we
understand a lot more about
our users our consumers the different
personas
shop differently and we're able to
understand their shopping habits
then we are able to better reach them
for their needs
so for example a young bachelor would
probably do a lot more
research online and then they like to go
to their stores
and feel the furniture and ask about
lifestyle tips after that every
marketing effort is a lot more targeted
strategic and obviously more productive
one exercise that we did a couple of
years back
was really looking at how our staff was
interacting with our customers
we actually built cardboard boxes of the
whole counter
and how the customer journey would be
when they move from one end to the other
end what were the pain points during the
whole process
so this actually shortened the queue
time for the customer
from the business point of view we
actually could serve more customers
in the same period of time compared to
previously
are you inspired by what scantique and
soup spoon have achieved
check out the design singapore council's
design for business
user journey mapping scheme a co-funding
assistance program with enterprise
singapore for
smes here are three different
customer journey map options to consider
option one
focuses on the research of one persona
this option is generally great for young
businesses
with a relatively small group of
customers
option two focuses on three to four
personas
it's ideal for companies who want to
expand and explore new customer segments
this option is great for businesses with
different products and deferring
customer needs
and finally option 3 which is a more
intricate system
that uses a service design blueprint
it's a diagram that visualizes the
relationship
among touch points processes and people
it's essentially how back-end operations
affect
front-end interactions with your
customers this option is great for
businesses that focus on service flow
all applications will be assessed by
enterprise singapore
based on project scope project outcomes
and the competency of service providers
successful companies could seek
up to eighty percent funding for all the
companies that are still considering
whether they want to get into
design banking and the methodology of uh
user journey mapping i say
go for it if you want to increase the
top line and bottom line of your
business
[Music]
the best way to do it is to fully
understand your customers
so you can better meet their needs so
your marketing dollars can be
better spent so start now wow your
customers with better experiences
and see how that transforms your
business
want to find out more about user journey
mapping
drop us an email or visit our website at
designsingapore.org